oftentimes people would say something
like hey guys I just wrote this new book
boo boring powerful opinion like what
are you staying for woman in the reps
practice practice practice and you will
get better
what's that belief nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn seven ways to be
great on camera even if you are an
introvert now this video is brought to
you by the making money from your ideas
workshop that I do in Toronto basically
teaching people how to be the mean of
your industry I haven't make money from
advertising book deals sponsorships
courses consulting all of that I have
you for three days where I'm gonna get
my hooks into you where I'm not just
teaching you exactly what I do but
working with you one-on-one to help you
do it too if you're interested check out
the link in the description below so
[Music]
does the question get asked a lot I want
to be a speaker I want to be a youtuber
I want to be great on camera I want to
be able to deliver my message as an
entrepreneur and get it out there to the
world but I don't know how to do it I
can't be great on camera I'm an
introvert I need help to do it and so
today I'm gonna share with you my seven
ways and how to be great on camera even
if you are an introvert now this comes
from and introvert myself I am NOT an
extroverted person I do not like talking
to the people on the airplane next to me
I don't go up and make random
conversations with people it took me
five thousand videos and training to get
at this point of where I am and my goal
is to condense that down for you so that
you can get really good in a much
shorter amount of time using these seven
techniques
[Music]
number one is lead with a powerful
opinion get used to leading your videos
with a powerful opinion that you have
that others don't as an example if I
wanted to pitch my book the top 10 roots
of success I could say something like
modeling success is your shortcut to
victory you do not need to have all the
answers worked out for yourself somebody
has already figured this out and your
shortcut is to learn from them and apply
their strategies to help you achieve
your goals lead with a powerful opinion
oftentimes people would say something
like hey guys I just wrote this new book
and the book is about success and if you
want to have success then this is the
book that you need to go and pick up boo
boring powerful opinion like what are
you staying for what is your opinion on
a topic if you cannot come up with an
opinion don't make a video practice this
your first sentence practice to your
next 10 videos your first sentence is
the powerful opinion that you have about
that topic lead with a powerful opinion
[Music]
number two is emotional commitment
understand that you're in the emotion
transfer business not just data and
facts transfer this is where a lot of
thought leaders fall down you have the
ideas you have the solutions you know
what people need to do in order to get a
result to fix their life to change their
business you know you have it but when
you get in front of a camera the
delivery falls flat and because there's
no emotion transfer between you and the
audience they are deaf to the message
that you are saying this is why a lot of
academics can never get their message
across academics have so much great
information they've done all the
research serve the cutting edge of what
needs to get done and they know what you
need to go off and do but because they
don't have emotional commitment in the
words when they're explaining things it
comes off as dry and boring so it's not
just about having a fax it's about
feeling every word that you are saying
while you are saying it and that's
really hard especially if you're not
comfortable in front of the camera at
the beginning that might mean you have
to do a hundred takes of a video don't
expect to get in front of a camera and
just spit out awesomeness right it may
take you 10 takes just to get the words
out just to become
with the knowledge that you're sharing
but after 10 don't stop go another 10 or
another 20 or another 30 or another 40
until you get to the point where you
have the word soul locked in but now you
can focus on the feeling because you are
in the emotion transfer game I need to
feel your passion and energy for what
you're saying and then I will listen to
the words that you are actually saying
[Music]
number 3 is racist aches you need to
make it important enough for the person
to want to take action because otherwise
they're gonna continue on with their
life doing the exact same thing they
were always doing forever and ever and
ever and never getting the result you
have the answer you have the knowledge
you know what this person needs to do to
solve this problem but unless you make
it more important unless you show the
consequence of them not taking action
then they very rarely will it's very
rare that somebody will watch a video
and then actually take immediate massive
action towards accomplishing that goal
they have to be really ready and in the
zone to do it or your emotional
commitment you're raising the stakes
your powerful opinion can help guide
them to shift them from them maybe I
should too I absolutely must and the way
to do that is to raise the stakes so you
have to show them how it's insanely
important for them to take action so if
I'm talking about the importance of
modeling success as an example I could
talk about modeling being that the
shortcut Mahlon is the path to get to
victory a lot faster right that's
showing the positive now show me the
consequences if you never learn to study
success you will continue to repeat the
same patterns and you have continued to
face over and over and over and over and
over again and you will never hit your
goal if you refuse to study from past
success
you will repeat their failures and will
never accomplish the mission that you
are off to accomplish something like
that right like make it more important
show me the consequences of my current
actions if I don't take the corrective
action that you want me to take raise
the stakes
[Music]
number four is eliminate filler words so
often we are afraid to offend somebody
we are afraid to be bold with our
opinions and that leads to a lot of
filler words that ends up happening that
prevents people from connecting to the
message and it doesn't make you look
like an authority who knows what they're
talking about so if you came on camera
and say hey guys so what I want to talk
to you about today is something that is
you know kind of important and I think
really needs to be discussed because I
see this so many times happening in my
business and and it's probably happened
in your business too and so that's why
I'm making this video and today I want
to talk about like get to the point what
are we talking about what is the message
what is your powerful opinion stop using
filler words and again a great way to do
this is to record yourself and then
watch it back are you leading with that
powerful opinion do you have the
emotional transfer do you feel confident
in what you're saying and can you reduce
the number of words that you're saying
to lead off the video especially I think
as you do is get better as videos go on
people they get better they find their
rhythm but I find especially at the
beginning you're hedging you're using a
lot of filler words and as a result
people are tuning it out because they
want to learn from a thought leader who
knows what they're talking about are the
expert and are confident in their
perspective so eliminate filler words
[Music]
number five we say I not we a lot of
bunch burns will default to thinking we
the Royal we we is a business we think
this and that can work in some
circumstances that makes you look a
little bigger than you are you want to
be inclusive I think especially as
Canadians we're a little more humble
than we want to always not offend
anybody and so we say we but when you
are a thought leader when you have our
powerful opinion when you need to get
your message across when you want
somebody to listen to you then you need
to say I you need to start getting used
to this is my opinion this is what I
stand forth is what I think needs to get
done this is what I think needs to
happen if you want to make this shift in
your business or your life here's what I
think what I know you
need to do it's confidence its
conviction and it has to be real has to
be based on you actually feel like this
is what they need to do don't get in
front of a camera and spit a bunch of
lies or half the truths or things that
you aren't certain of but if you know
this is the path you've seen this
mistake happen over and over and over
and over again and you know that they
need to do this thing then you have to
be confident then you have to say that
this is coming from you you're
showcasing your expertise your opinions
they matter they make a difference and
you know that you are right because
again it's about the transfer of energy
in this case it's about the transfer of
certainty that you are certain in your
opinion and if they feel that certainty
then they will take action that should
be your goal and so if you eliminate the
we and you replace it with an eye that
starts a shift and make the difference
now you may not be able to catch it in
the moment one of the things I would
highly recommend again is watch your
videos back and see how many times did
you say we versus I we versus I you can
script out your first powerful opinion
you can have a line that your write down
and that's the one you're gonna go for
but then watch those videos back and the
more you can catch those Wiis and knock
them off and put I in place you will
start to convert a lot better and bring
people on board with your perspective
say I not we number 6 is practice
practice practice you are just not
putting in enough practice on video to
get good at it as I mentioned it took me
five thousand videos plus to get to
where I'm at right now it was a lot of
practice when I started at the agency
that I was at they told me I was the
worst speaker in the agency and within a
couple months it became the best not
because I'm good I actually had a lot
working against me I'm I'm introverted
remember I don't have a lot of these
natural skills and talents built in but
I worked I work with my agent and he'd
give me an assignment and I would make a
video and then I send it to him and I'd
send him again at lunch after he gave me
feedback he gave me feedback I'd do it
again for dinner so three times a day I
was making videos and send them to him
for feedback were the best people that
you can see we're making one video a
week and having a hard time justifying
putting in more practice time and so I
quickly got better than them
within a couple months I became the best
practice at the agency again not because
I am skill they're talented but because
I put in a lot of work and so by default
I think you should never accept the
first take by default you film it never
accept the first thing do it again if
only just to get the energy level up
because the first time you get on camera
you press a chord
you're just you're not used to it even
if you're not nervous because you've
done it before just the first time is
never the best and so by default you're
always doing at least one take I would
then look at at what point have i
memorised the words that I feel
comfortable with it not that it's good
lying for lying word-for-word exactly
but you're not stumbling over the words
because at the beginning you're trying
to think what am I trying to say I'm not
getting that what am I trying to say so
do enough takes that you feel like
you've gotten the message out the words
and then the last bit is the emotional
commitment now do you know the words
that you're saying you practice telling
that with emotion with energy try to
imagine here's the exercise of mine she
gave me try to imagine somebody's gonna
jump off a bridge they are about to jump
off a bridge and your message is the
last thing that they're gonna hear
before they jump and they really care
the problem that you're solving this is
what they have right the message of this
video is the exact problem that they
have you need to pull them off the
bridge now that's that's that sounds
extreme but for some people that's
actually where they are like if you are
helping them with their business somehow
a lot of people will kill themselves
it sounds dark it sounds big it sounds
drastic but a lot of people go down that
really dark path and if you just take
the mindset of I can save people like
they're about to make a huge mistake and
I can save them with this video try to
imagine somebody it's another technique
try to think of somebody who you've
helped recently so that you're not just
talking to a lens but you imagine
talking to another human being so you
practice and you practice and you
practice and you practice and you
practice until you watch that video back
and say that was the best that I've ever
done that video that I just recorded was
the best that I can do with my skill set
talent right now maybe in five months
I'll get better the right now that was
the best be proud of the work that you
were creating every single time that
comes like putting in the reps at the
beginning I would
at least 25 takes on every single video
that you were putting out put in the
reps practice practice practice and you
will get better and number seven is
model success you are not the first
person to try not be in front of a
camera and be a great speaker find the
people who you look up to who you
respect who've done it before you and
watch them and get their energy and get
their charisma and understand how they
tell their jokes and find their rhythm
and their flow use it as a kick forward
not down so for me my hero from a
speaking world is Les Brown young Les
Brown old Les Brown now is is this
jovial grandfatherly kind of guy but
young Les Brown had fire had passion had
spirit and listen I may never get to
that point you know I don't want to be
exact photocopy of Les Brown and I may
never get to his level of energy and
passion he had when he was a young
speaker but it's an aspiration I look at
that and I get inspired and so whoever
it is that you look up to whether it's
the yell in your face like Eric Thomas
or the massive passion energy like Tony
Robbins or the more subtle Tom tones
maybe you love the Dalai Lama
maybe you love Wayne Dyer maybe you love
Zig Ziglar maybe you love Oprah Winfrey
like everybody has their own style
that's okay whose style resonates the
most with you and then try to surround
yourself with that and especially before
going on to record a video watch one of
these people watch one of your heroes
speaking one just to get a sense in
flavor of their style but also just that
energy transfer they are transferring
you energy that then you will transfer
into your camera and your audience model
success so those are my seven tips on
how to be great in front of the camera
I'd love to know which one resonated the
most with you which one do you need to
work on the most did I miss an eight
nine ten that you want to add to the
list let me know down in the comments
below
raise your standard apple at the core
its core values is that we believe that
people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn how to win on social media
check out the video right next to me
where I give you my 7 best tips on how
to win on social continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you are chasing
something just because you think it's an
opportunity and you have no genuine
passion for it stop right now it's a
waste of time